voilà la charte vient d'être signée par
huit organisations professionnelles de
martinique
c'est l'aboutissement de plusieurs
réunions portant essentiellement sur
l'octroi de mer le régime actuel de
cette taxe arrivé à échéance
les instants signataires veulent
conserver le dispositif avec cependant
un calcul différent car selon elle les
industries locales sont lésés par
rapport aux grandes entreprises de
métropole nous prenons le cas de l'eau
une bouteille d'eau produite localement
et une bouteille d'eau produits importés
la bouteille d'eau produite localement
supporte des avantages en terme
d'étroitesse de marché en termes de
coûts plus importants concernant la main
d'oeuvre en termes également de
transport de ces matières premières donc
tous ces éléments font que produire
localement revient souvent plus chers
que des portes et l'autre mère une taxe
controversée qui n'arrange pas forcément
les affaires de toutes les entreprises
mais dans la charte des signataires
rappellent qu'il participe grandement au
développement de l'industrie locale
depuis sa création il a permis aux
entreprises de générer plus d'un
milliard de chiffre d'affaires et de
créer plus de 40000 emplois
la disparition de cette taxe serait
selon quelques professionnels
une catastrophe pour l'économie du pays
s'il n'y avait plus ce différentiel
nous perdrions très certainement des
parts de marché importantes et nous
serions plus en mesure d'assurer la
capacité de production nous avons
aujourd'hui en résultat on serait obligé
de rétrécir on perdait des parts de
marché dans son objet de rétrécir notre
emprise et donc notre effectif est
probablement entrer dans des difficultés
financières extrêmement importantes pour
l'entreprise
il faut savoir que l'octroi de mer
compense le budget des collectivités
exemple à ducos sur 21 millions de
budget annuel 8 millions proviennent de
cette taxe soit près de 40% du budget si
elle est supprimée l'on peut imaginer
une augmentation des impôts locaux pour
combler le manque
ce qui aurait un impact direct sur le
pouvoir d'achat de la population
cette charte qui comporte un certain
nombre de propositions des instants
signataires sera remise aux élus
martiniquais qui feront suivre au
gouvernement